so I have what is really not good news
about the show and this has nothing to
do with a YouTube advertiser boycott
although the timing of it is not ideal
you'll remember that at the beginning of
April the YouTube advertiser boycott
started and this caused a huge reduction
in our YouTube ad revenue and that in
and of itself made some news in fact the
New York Times wrote an article about
what was happening with our YouTube
channel Amanda Hess wrote this article
how YouTube's shifting algorithms heard
independent media several months ago
there was a follow-up article about the
david pakman show youtube channel from
Wired magazine where Davey Alba followed
up by writing another really well
researched article and we started
crawling out of this using both
membership and patreon and revenue on
YouTube started to recover we have a
revenue graph that we're showing our
television audience and where we started
the year very strong and then completely
fell off a cliff it looked like a round
point 3 on this graph revenue was
starting to recover and then at the
beginning of July at the end of this
graph it fell off a cliff so we've been
talking about membership we've been
talking about patreon and now we are
under threat of lawsuit I could tell you
everything about this but sort of out of
respect and an effort to resolve this
without it escalating to an actual
actual lawsuit I'm going to sort of give
you the basics of what's going on and
hopefully at some point once this is
done or if and when we are actually sued
I will go fully public on the details
there's this thing called patent
trolling and there's a similar cousin to
it called copyright trolling the bottom
line is that we have received a demand
letter alleging that we have infringed
on someone's copyright this relates to
an image or video that was used on the
program at some point over the last
several years and I know I'm being
deliberately vague and it's again
because I'm hoping that we can resolve
this without it going to some kind of
actual lawsuit or trial but we have
received a letter demanding many many
thousands of dollars and I have spoken
with a number of different people who
have been subjected to the same types of
demand letters and the bottom line is
and I've been
super transparent with the law firm that
is threatening the lawsuit if we can't
come up with these many many thousands
of dollars I said listen we we don't
have the money to to settle this thing
and to pay off your demand letter and if
we did we'd have hired an attorney so
that you could be talking to the
attorney instead of talking to me who's
not an attorney and doesn't really know
what's going on and the bottom line is
that we if you sue us we're also not
going to all of a sudden have money to
start paying thousands and thousands of
dollars plus attorneys fees and possible
damages so what I'm coming to you with
in the audience is if there's an
attorney in our audience who handles
intellectual property and might help us
out pro bono with this please get in
touch because I'm basically taking the
approach of we do not believe that we
did anything wrong our policy is not to
violate copyright we are a program that
is out there serving non commercial
interests on non commercial radio and
television stations we don't have the
money to pay off such a demand letter
but really if we had an attorney who
actually is is a us-based attorney
specializing in intellectual property it
would really be useful if you could get
in touch and if if you're not an
attorney this would be once again a
really great time to consider making a
financial contribution to the show
because between the advertiser boycott
and now the potential lawsuit demand for
money and/or legal fees that we could
end up having to pay here we do need
whatever support we can gather from the
audience so number one membership is
available you go to david pakman.com
slash membership membership started only
$6 a month or 60 for the year if you
want a discount off of those prices you
can use the coupon code I voted 17 it
will save you 40 percent still benefits
the show significantly you'll get all
the same member benefits and you can
also just throw in a couple of bucks via
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show even as little as $1 a month
does help so you can check that out
that's the latest I hope it does not
escalate to a lawsuit because we are not
equipped right now to deal with in
addition to the YouTube ad boycott a
copyright lawsuit which is what
is being threatened here but that's
where we are and we're going to do the
best we can and if you are an
intellectual property attorney who might
be able to lend some legal help pro bono
ideally take over this thing and and
hopefully help us resolve it please get
in touch through our website contact
form